it's true that's true it's they don't
understand what it's like to be a girl
no
it's easy it's easier to
be more vocal about stuff and be able to
express your opinion when you've had
that opportunity to do it your whole
life and you've been in situations where
you've been able to express yourself and
not have
certain repercussions happen to you and
it's like it's hard to
start doing that or try to do that when
it's been something that you haven't
been able to do our society
really says you shouldn't shouldn't do
no i mean we didn't like grow up like
that yeah and that's why i think the
older generation they didn't grow up
with social media mm-hmm so they're like
why don't you just say your opinions
yeah we're like i've seen every
influencer get cancelled since 2010
we're saying the wrong thing like
canceled culture is so big it's like
what is the wrong thing is the wrong
thing something that you don't agree
with so that makes it wrong
and so all these other people that agree
with me are wrong as well i should this
is what i've noticed actually
whenever i see a clip and i get kind of
like offended by it
it's because the shoe fits a little bit
yeah
and what i've noticed is that the more
like like the angrier someone gets it's
because the shoe fits
and
yeah that's that's what i've i've
noticed i feel like there is some cases
where cancer culture hack has has been
good because it's like pedophiles i'll
give them
we can cancel pedophiles um one with
the
case that happened in the summer um some
guy that was gonna be like a record
label guy he his girlfriend like posted
videos of her him abusing her and um he
was about to like get a big record label
deal and she posted it like just before
he was about to do that and like there
was videos of her like screaming and
crying and everyone's like oh do you
think do you think that's okay to cancel
him without going to court i feel like
because because you have no idea if she
was hitting hitting him first a lot of
people did like because it's like the
timing was a bit
like
yeah yeah yeah time's a bit crazy but
then at the same time if it is true that
he
like if he's gone to court and he
actually was like
beating her and stuff it's like
he doesn't well who i might say he
doesn't deserve what he's worked hard
for but i just feel like
that's the consequences of the actions
that you've done well i think it's i
think it's cool like to cancel someone
if they're found guilty but a lot of
times like the media becomes public
opinion yeah and it's like the court
the court of public opinion isn't always
correct
and the media can as well
what sometimes that's the court of law
as well no that's true
whatever the court thinks is true it's
truth but but the problem is in the us
it's like it's pretty hard to convict
someone of something like it's like
because the u.s
it's
it's innocent no no you are okay
no you're right that's true there's like
money like someone gets a good lawyer
they can get out of something but like
like i i've like gone to i've like
pressed charges again it's harder than
you think
i'll say something from back in the day
a person's name and i was like let me
not say that
um
so i don't know i just think like it's
easier like to post a video and paint
someone as something than it is to
convict someone yeah it's never it's
never gonna be perfect right and
you never know how true and i'm not i'm
not discrediting the situation but we
often
we often
without like
and when it comes to
when it comes to
women
there's like a
well like what happened and i don't know
if that would be vice versa like if it
was if she was going into um
a big record
label and had like a contract or
whatever and she was about to blow up
and he posted a video uh
would we question like well like why why
now
does that make sense i i think
like we have believe all women
i don't understand because there's some
crazy ass [ __ ] yeah that will
purposely that will purposely and i'm
not i'm not saying that that was her
yeah
they would purposely put themselves in
certain positions to ruin
someone's
complete life like um there was
um
a boy years ago he
was supposed to be a top prospect for a
college no it was either for a college
or to go pro
and this um girl wasn't the one that we
talked about that one time but this girl
said that um
she he like
i don't know what the word is that one
great grape there you go grapefruit and
his dreams were shattered and then years
later it comes to find out that it
wasn't even him or the situation didn't
even happen and it's like
how do we how do we get to that
what wouldn't why why do we just believe
hearsay she's
like
why and that's but that's even like what
we do with videos because you have no
idea what happened before like she could
have hit him over the head with a chair
before the video and then he freaked out
yeah
personally
if i was a man that someone hit me over
the channel who you are i'm knocking you
i'm rocking you across the face
but i think like i don't know we i think
women and men have this like innate
instinct to like protect women a little
bit yeah because even when i post [ __ ]
on tick tock if i'm going in on like a
girl like like bill even if she's wrong
and i think again i feel it too because
sometimes when i'm like
i'm going at someone it's like really
hard for me because i'm like i'm sorry
yeah i'm sorry and they could be wrong i
like apologize to people after like i'm
like i'm sorry it's just part of the
show
i meant what i said but i'm sorry yeah
it's hard it's hard as
as hard as women that's why when we were
um
i can't remember his name he was here
that one time i won't know it oh you you
know his name um the guy next was he
sitting next to purple sarah yeah
like he was here and he was asking if we
tell our friends like you look fat or
like nah you don't look good in that
it's like we
we
don't say it like see it like that yeah
there's a situation
um that some of my friends were telling
me about that happened and one of our
friends
she she didn't smell too good and i
don't even know if they said anything to
her and it was just like oh y'all just
gonna let her walk around smelling like
that and i'm like did anybody say
anything and it's just hard because it's
like
when something's wrong
we want to
not hurt somebody by not telling them
but you not saying something is just as
wrong
i think women like naturally we want to
say what makes people feel good rather
than what is like true yeah
and i i think like
i don't need to but i do sugarcoat a lot
of things yeah no i do that's like why
um i mean that's why people watch me is
because they're not used to and i think
i say it most of the time pretty nice
and like not even like you should see
some of the other podcasts that do
similar like they are not they're like
stop wifi
when i'm like look at these studies i
mean if you like
yeah no i i understand what you do
but it's like
and i feel like men don't understand
that's what i'm saying because men can
just do it because they've that's
that's how it's been for them they can
just do it and then not come off
a certain way unless they
say it a certain way we could be like oh
my gosh like wow
amani i just want to let you know
something like this is this this and i
could say with the sweetest voice and it
could offend it could defend her just
because i can't i said something
bad about her but unless like we think
of each other as enemies sometimes as
well women like you could be you could
be saying it in the nicest way but in my
head i'm like this girl does not like me
do you know what i mean yeah yeah
instantly like was like because it's a
woman saying it to me um
like she doesn't like me yeah like she
thinks something do you know i mean yep
yeah
well and i think like i think that's
women's superpower right like i think
like being like more emotional and
empathetic like that's our superpower i
just think we've gotten to a place in
society where it's too far like i think
being able to say something in a kind
way to someone that's not a negative
thing yeah not at all it's just negative
when we can't
like express it when we're letting men
in the women's division because we want
to be nice yeah
and they're beating
now that we come full circle yes
96 oh we got to over 100 live viewers